The third episode of Game of Thrones’ eighth
season saw Arya Stark go from a woman to a
warrior.
Entitled "The Long Night," the latest chapter
in Game of Thrones' final season centered
on the battle between the Night King and his
Army of Dead and the living citizens of Westeros
holding strong at Winterfell.
The episode also featured more incredible
moments than we can count on one hand.
Lots of spoilers beyond this point, obviously.
The Red Priestess Melisandre made a surprise
return, uniting fire with ice by calling on
the Lord of Light to set the Dothraki outriders'
weapons on fire.
Daenerys Targaryen and Jon Snow rode atop
their respective dragons and attempted to
burn out the enemy with flames from above.
Several characters, like little Lyanna Mormont
and Jorah Mormont sacrificed themselves battling
the wights.
Theon Greyjoy died defending Bran Stark, and
the dead in the crypts of Winterfell rose
and began a terrifying attack on innocent
women, children, and elderly citizens.
As intense as these events surrounding the
Battle of Winterfell were, they felt like
small fish compared to what Arya Stark did
at the end of the episode.
The youngest Stark sister made "The Long Night"
that much more memorable by ending the very
event for which the entire episode was named.
In a moment few saw coming, Arya jumped at
the Night King and stabbed him, driving her
Valyrian steel dagger through an exposed section
of his armor.
The second the blade made contact with the
frosty villain's abdomen, the Night King shattered
to smithereens - as did his army of White
Walkers and wights.
Arya’s heroic surprise stunt dropped viewers'
jaws and elicited screams of delight from
Game of Thrones fans.
As the episode aired live on HBO, viewers
lit up social media with real-time reactions
to Arya slaying the Night King.
One fan tweeted:
"My head hurts from screaming since the episode
started but man… this moment was just amazing!
Arya Stark, well done queen.
Arya killing the night king is probably one
of the most iconic moments in this show.
A truly amazing scene."
Game of Thrones fan Cameron Stokes could barely
contain his emotions over Arya stabbing the
Night King and defeating the North’s greatest
threat.
Stokes posted to Twitter:
"Tonight was simply the most incredible 125
min in tv history, Arya is my favorite TV
character of all time…
That is all."
Evidence suggests that Arya's true destiny
was to slaughter the Night King and his army
- and this seemed to be confirmed during a
chat she had with Melisandre.
Before setting out to save the day - or night,
as it happens - Arya finds herself face-to-face
with the Red Woman, who brings up the notion
of purpose in regard to Beric Dondarrion,
the man who sacrificed himself protecting
Arya from wights in the library of Winterfell.
Melisandre reminds Arya of Beric’s history
of dying multiple times, only to be brought
back to life by the Lord of Light - suggesting
that he had been kept alive so he could save
Arya during the Battle of Winterfell, ensuring
she would be alive to defeat the Night King.
During their conversation, Arya corroborates
Melisandre's claim of soothsaying when she
remembers that the Red Woman previously prophesied
that the youngest Stark girl would take the
lives of many people.
This eerie prophecy happened all the way back
in season 3, when Arya confronted Melisandre
for taking her best friend, Gendry, away for
blood magic purposes.
Melisandre told Arya she saw a darkness in
the young girl, before alluding to the number
of people she would go on to kill:
"Brown eyes, blue eyes, green eyes.
Eyes you’ll shut forever."
"We will meet again."
Melisandre repeats her prophecy during the
third episode of season 8, rewording the phrase
about the eyes to place emphasis on the blue
ones that Arya will shut.
The scrappy Stark girl seems to take this
to mean that Melisandre has seen into a future
in which she kills the Night King, who has
blue eyes.
Arya's mind is made up already, but Melisandre
seals the deal when she asks Arya the same
question her first sword-fighting instructor
Syrio Forel used to:
"What do we say to
the God of Death?"
"Not today."
Arya’s killing of the Night King could impact
another of major prophecy that Melisandre
often spoke of: Azor Ahai, also known as the
Prince That Was Promised, who is prophesied
to end the Long Night and provide Westeros
with everlasting peace.
Melisandre told Daenerys during season 7 that
"only the Prince Who Was Promised can bring
the dawn," and that she believed Dany had
"a role to play" in the Long Night ending.
She also shared with the Mother of Dragons
that Jon Snow would be pivotal to ringing
in a new era - but there was no mention of
Arya.
So, does this mean the Azor Ahai prophecy
is… pointless?
Maybe, but then again, maybe not.
Arya still has a set of green eyes to shut
- green eyes many fans believe belong to Cersei
Lannister who’s presumably sitting cool
as a cucumber down in King's Landing.
Some are theorizing that maybe the Long Night
isn't over just yet and that it will only
come to an end when Arya kills the real threat
to Westeros: Cersei and her big green eyes.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Game of
Thrones are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.